good morning Millennials welcome back to
new heights I'm Jason I'm Trav and this
is the number one podcast in the world
we're brothers we're feeling a little
Southern today we're football players
we're Ballers man Jay good to for Life
bro ball is life football is life it's
good to see you Jace looking well how's
the fam fam is good Trav I don't even
feel like I need to ask cuz I see you
everywhere bro how you doing I'm feeling
good feeling good last you ready to rock
the stage you ready to rock the stage
Rock the stage at our Hood I got my girl
I mean we lost this weekend but she's
here hey T she's here in Kansas City we
won Eagles 7 And1 Jaylen Herz Fly Eagles
Fly on the road to
Victory
fly fly I'm still me you know I'm still
me but Jason does sing has I heard your
Christmas albums dropping yeah bro I
can't wait you know proceeds going back
to the community love my community Fly
Eagles Fly uh and I love to sing you
know just cuz you're not good at
something doesn't mean you shouldn't do
it well you know who else you know who
else is on the album my
man who
me are you yeah I was listening to their
podcast this morning Travis I just want
to say Travis is on the album the team
came to Kansas City to record it with
him and I think Taylor's going to be on
it because she loves the Eagles and
she'll want give back to the community
that's my call an amazing call thank you
I literally can't I literally I
literally can't talk in this beard I
cannot talk in this beard it's so
[__] itchy and sweaty I'm dying I
can't talk in this mustache when we get
into the show we will take off our
facial hair but for now we got to rock
the stage bro we got to rock the stage
at Arrowhead this weekend what's the at
linoln Financial this
weekend it doesn't roll off the tong it
doesn't have that flow that killer tra
flow now today's episode is toasta
weekend toasta weekend what's it called
toasta ween um and it's a very special
episode it's kind of like a collab New
Heights X the toast you know but we're
not really an interview based
show however today we make an exception
cuz we've got an extremely special guest
here on New Heights today who you got
bro you know her we love
her people call her Donna but we call
her mama Kelsey everybody in the room I
want a round of applause for today's
guest it's Donna
Kelsey
mama oh my sons mama I missed you oh
Travis you look so good oh I love your
mustache mom's in a building Donna mama
you look beautiful I miss you mama oh I
miss you Trev I love the way you've
parted your hair oh Trev you're looking
so fly thanks Mama just like you taught
me back in the day oh Trev oh hello
Jason oh you've you really your but is
mighty Bonny you're losing way too
quickly Jason you know it's that Eagle's
diet fly eagle fly ma ma I know you get
asked a lot but now that you know you're
on our podcast we want the exclusive
what's it like having two kids in the
NFL and let's be real who do you like
better maybe the one who give you
grandbabies oh it's pretty amazing oh I
don't really care who gives me the grand
babies I care who gives me the Home who
paying up for me house what who's paying
up for me house but ma ma ma hey Ma but
I brought you Taylor Ma you love me now
t ma oh I don't know who this tayor
woman could be who is
she my lady my love Ma you met her at
the game ma we got to put you in a home
already oh trailer Swift oh I don't know
her I don't know her but I know her and
I love her but I don't know her it's
okay Ma it's okay it's a lot to keep go
you know got multiple games multiple
cities multiple boys it's a lpma oh it's
mighty hard Mighty hard being Donna
Donna Donna dfire has joined us on the
podcast today it's mighty hard being
Donna doubt
fire ma ma tra and I want to know like
you know your whole life has changed
you're you're a celeb how's it feel ma
how's it feel great oh I be getting that
bu light money oh it's good the
sponsorships are through the roof we are
paying for school oh it's great in
school oh I send all the children I meet
to school I have nine of them that I've
sent to elementary middle and high
school oh we bake on the weekends oh we
listen to Taylor
Swift I'm raising more kids than you
know you're not my only kids M you got
some cookies for me I need your cookies
ma oh oh I did bring you some cookies oh
oh you see freshly baked freshly baked
in this Rubbermaid this
is this is brought to you by
Rubbermaid this is my new million dooll
sponsorship ma ma what kind of cookies
are those oh they're black and white
cookies oh they're very good let me show
you one Ma I think you need to go to the
dentist your breath
stinks hey don't talk to ma like that oh
Jason you are always an ass oh oh you've
been an ass for a long time ma ma am I
your favorite oh yes yes Travis oh yes
you have that bushy brow that clean hair
you're looking like a news reporter oh
Trav you look so good oh my I just want
to make you proud M just want to make
you proud oh you make me proud every
weekend scoring those touchdowns unlike
Jason who scor nothing who scor nothing
Jason scores nothing
maybe if you had less kids oh you'd
score more
touchdowns oh oh my
Jason oh Jason oh my
Jason oh okay you're my favorite Jason
gives me things Tris can't give me
through
Zoom ma ma you coming to Kansas soon oh
yes I'm coming to Kansas oh I hear they
have a delicious spread oh the brisket
and
it's not like your brisket ma no it's
not oh no Trev Trav what happened to
your mustache wait why am I
Jamaican tra what happened to your
mustache bro listen bro I'm trying on a
new look my barber's got me all mixed up
oh oh no she's mixed he's mixed up oh no
oh I think oh my my hair's cut in my lip
oh yeah hold
on okay Ben in this look is everything
he walked here I'm Vlogging today he
walked here in full clothing and wig no
wig makeup no wig so he really just
looked like a very stylish feminine
woman and honestly he was also carrying
my purse for me which is like a neutral
which really went with his outfit we
were literally cackling in the street
that is so funny M you look amazing you
look amazing so thank you so much oh
thank you mat thanks for being here we
love you we know you're busy
and we'll see you in uh Philadelphia
this weekend boy boy
BR Eagles go I mean Fly Eagles
Fly go Eagles Go Fly Eagles
Fly y give it up for Donna Kelsey thank
you oh thank you I love you Ma oh love
you Trev
oh by the way if we were watch rein live
and we had a drinking game would be like
take a shot every time Ben
says oh you took your mustache off I'm
so jealous my beard is like underneath
my wig I don't think I
can oh a little
release oh my God this a good look for
you though no the thing is the way if I
had short hair and a beard and I
literally didn't need to put makeup on
my entire face and like literally or do
my hair today was a real exercise and
how much easier men have it I mean isn't
that the
truth we've got a great show it's toasta
we 2023 we had a very special alist
guest Donna Kelsey was in the building
and it's gonna be a great list I got my
girl here tayor Taylor's rocking the
basement
where I'm trying I'm being subtle low
key yeah yeah that's her the best I'm
sure everyone saw her on her plane yeah
my girl's got a plane yeah that's nice I
mean my girl gave me three grandbabies
no not Grands my girl gave me three
three of the loves of my life that's
beautiful I love how are my nieces doing
oh you know Kylie and the other one
whose names I don't know Kylie's your
wife bro oh [__] um Wyatt
Wyatt and uh Tate and Sarah they're
doing good bro they're doing real good
thanks for asking I miss them tell them
Uncle Trav loves them I'll tell him baby
girl Uncle Travy loves you Uncle Travy
loves you Uncle Travy has got a big
heart full of love oh I've got so much
love to give do you think the kids have
met
Taylor I don't know if it's worked out
yet but I'm sure that it's going to
happen by the way my Jason Kelsey is
also giving Paul nassi like you're
always giving Paul Nassif maybe I am
Paul nassi like that's the answer no and
I'm always giving Prince Harry because
I'm just Prince Harry right like once
you put that costume on you were indel
no it left an indelible Mark yeah for
sure I think Trav and Prince Harry are
kind of similar I think so too like a
little
thirsty yeah Trav is just like more
overt like he doesn't have to pretend to
be someone he's
not I I could see that I guess just
Harry has to you know be buttoned up but
he wants to let loose he's in Hollywood
baby right I thought he would actually
let loose more now that he's in
Hollywood letting loose takes
time yeah I also love sitting like a man
on the podcast today I'm sitting like a
man like character it feels so good it's
so weird to wear shorts yeah I'm wearing
like basketball shorts Under Armour my
sponsor bro oh yeah same bro Fly Eagles
Fly on the road to
Victory Fly Eagles Fly from the Hun and
to the stay
e a g l e s I forget how that song goes
they got a good song over there yeah and
what do we have the
chomp oh I don't know is that you have
we have like the Arro head chop thank
God we've been spending the last couple
of weeks watching a lot of football in
preparation for this it's been research
and development it's so true we barely
had to do it I watch the
documentary that gave me more info on
you Brethren than on me yeah Jason's
hard to get into character cuz like he's
normal yeah
he's just like a guy he's like a dad
yeah he's got a big personality did you
ever see that video of him when they won
the Super B Twilight oh no when they won
the Super Bowl he gave a speech to his
City and it's [__] crazy yes I did
and that's really made him a household
name in his City and do you know what he
looked like a few years ago like before
he got famous he's ever changing he
looks like a character on Game of
Thrones like he literally had hair like
it was huge like and the biggest beard
you've ever seen he's just like this big
man he looked like literally a character
in Game of Thrones I feel like if Game
of Thrones were on now and he was a fan
he'd be one of the celebs that like got
a little Cameo like um
Aaron and cheeran yeah Chris Stapleton
underrated cute thing they did so
underrated and so cute I'm glad they
only like chose people who actually look
like some of the characters even though
Aaron's kind of a stretch Ed Sheeran Ed
Sheeran literally was born in the wrong
generation yeah he's
perfect wat you know what's interesting
I feel like women's looks like change so
much throughout history and over time
cuz Trends change but men like are just
men I guess their hairstyles change but
like it's not like they're getting fake
lips fake lashes yeah women's like style
changes are so much more drastic men's
are really just like clothes in hair
like a man from today looks the same as
a man from a hundred years
ago yeah but a woman today looks
completely different she's got beachy
waves right right you think they're
doing beachy waves in France no no um so
we've got a gorgeous show today it's
toast it's the greatest time of year and
it's here and I'm ready to dive in are
you yeah we've got some D stories
Brethren um but we're really just here
to shake things up you know shake up the
C Shake Up Chicago we're the number one
podcast in the world right now everyone
wants a piece of the Brethren yeah it's
kind of uh this costume is actually
really easy for me to get into cuz like
they're siblings who everyone's obsessed
with and we're siblings who everyone's
obsessed with and they do a podcast it a
remote podcast it oh this is our first
toen doing remote and honestly couldn't
have come in a better time it makes more
sense to have done this remote than to
do it together because if you look at
their show it looks like our show except
like not as
srly not as swirly and definitely not as
twirly and not as
surely you said it there
Brethren oh without further ad do I
think so here are the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by caroy hosting the
season just got easier with carway from
roasting your first ever first ever
turkey to making pancakes for tenant
brunch the square wear set has you
covered caraway's internet famous
kitchen wear is a staple for any home
and it comes in a variety of modern
Shades that fit with any design
aesthetic car homes non-toxic kitchen
wear features a chemical-free ceramic
coating so food can be prepared with
peace of mind that no hardto pronounce
chemicals will leech into your healthy
ingredients I used my caroway last night
made literally the most delicious meal
my first meal ever made in my house Ben
loved it caroway was one pot dish OPD
caroway stunning so easy to clean slick
surface it's made of ceramic there's no
scrubbing it's non-toxic so there
products are made without any toxic
materials so you know that that crap
isn't leeching into your uh delicious
healthy ingredients that you just bought
at the grocery store it's also well-
loved over 50,000 people have raved
about their Caraway kitchen wear so now
it's time to try it for yourself visit
carway home.com theeast to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10% off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
Caraway home.com toast or use code the
toast at checkout caraway's products are
everything whether it's their food
storage solutions their pots and pans I
love their Dutch oven perfect for a a
chili on a cold Winter's day love the
pan friends love everything that they
offer and their products are really well
made and they're good for you and your
family so again that's code the toast or
carway home.com theeast carway non-toxic
cookware made Modern today's episode is
also brought to you by zbiotics let's
face it after a night of drinking we
don't bounce back the next day like we
used to so we have to make a choice I
can either have a great night or a great
next day and that is until we found
zbiotics a pre- alcohol probiotic it is
the first the world's first genetically
engineered probiotic it was invented by
PhD scientists to tackle rough mornings
after drinking here's how it works when
you drink alcohol gets converted into a
toxic byproduct in your gut it's this
byproduct not dehydration that's to
blame for your rough next day zbiotics
produces an enzyme to break this
byproduct down it's designed to work
like your liver but in your gut where
you need it most just remember to drink
zbiotics before drinking alcohol drink
responsibly and get a good night's sleep
to feel your best tomorrow so the first
time I tried zbiotics was a few weeks
ago as instructed I drink the bottle of
zbiotics before having any alcohol and I
was really amazed at how good I felt the
next day cuz I'm in my Wellness era and
I've been really hesitant to you know
have a drink at dinner because it ruins
my whole next day you know like I got to
hit the gym go I'm trying to get swo so
zbiotics is a fabulous option and you
can go to zbiotics docomo to get 15% off
your first order when you use code toast
at checkout you can also sign up for a
subscription using our code so you can
stay prepared no matter the time or
occasion zbiotics is backed with 100%
money back guarantee so if if you're
unsatisfied for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember to head to zbiotics docomo and
use code toast at checkout for 15% off
thank you zbiotics for sponsoring this
episode today's episode is also brought
to you by skims you guys already know
that we are obsessed with skims it all
started with their fits everybody
collection with the butteriest underwear
ever so we wanted to try more from the
brand now I've been seeing a lot of
their cotton lounger all over Instagram
and Tik Tok so we had to see what the
hype was about and let me tell you it
did not disappoint the cutest and most
flattering sets you'll find for in or
out of the house so I've been wearing
skims for now like many years I love all
their products the cotton loungewear
hits different I love something that I
can lounge around in in my house but if
I have to sorry I have like a beard hair
in my mouth but if I have to like walk
Theo in it like I hate to I to change
clothes for my house clothes just to go
outside so super appropriate for the
outdoors great for the indoors super
comfortable and skims is just creating
the next generation of loungewear for
every single person um their cotton
jersey shirts are Fab fabulous they're
bralette when I get home my bra comes
off but I'm not the type of girl who
could just walk around like freeballing
without a bra I love Ben calls them
their my relaxation bras they're
technically called a bralette they're
from skims they're made of the most
stretchy Jersey material it's just good
for my back it's good for my home it's
just good for everything it is Ski's
most tagged collection it's made with a
classic cotton fabric for comfortable
everyday wear and it's made from an
Ultra Soft natural fiber the cotton
collection features elevated Lounge
pieces designed for Comfort indoors and
outside whoever said loungewear was only
for the house hasn't tried skims and
they're available in sizes extra extra
small to 4X so believe the hype skims
has over 100,000 festar reviews for a
reason the cotton collection and more
are available now at skims.com plus get
free shipping on orders over $75 if you
haven't yet be sure to let them know
that the toast sent you after you place
your order select podcast in the survey
survey and select our show in the drop-
down menu and if you missed the big news
skims reinvented underwear for women and
now they're doing it for men also
available at
skims.com thanks Brethren you're welcome
I love I love m skims oh skims for men
man like I'm actually Jackie you don't
love skims I don't oh I don't my girl
are you okay uh yeah no I was a little
Bumm not to be in that ad that was some
pretty cool shots should have been us
bro should have been us should have been
us oh sorry let me sit like a man should
have been us bro should have been us
well the first story is about me because
isn't everything days me me my girl
Taylor landed back in Kansas City after
my big loss to the Broncos this was a
bummer Man Taylor returned to see me in
Kansas City Missouri will always be
confusing Monday after my loss against
de Denver Broncos page six can confirm
and so can I because she's right here
the song sh jetted back to my side in
the morning taking off from moristown
New Jersey The Daily Mail reported my
girls PJ was spotted touching down at
the airport before her team packed her
bags lisis Vuitton I bought them for her
I saw those bags those were so notail I
know I thought the same thing I feel
like she's in her luxury like not she's
in her Travis label era oh yeah those
bags are so Travis so Travis he probably
left them at her house and she was just
like bring did you also see that article
like Selena Gomez sources say is really
worried that Taylor Swift is moving too
fast yeah I saw that she's not my
favorite friend of my girls oh wow
Travis X Selena there's drama there's a
little yeah yeah definitely didn't
Sayers I don't like definitely didn't
say that I feel like it's something
Selena would say I feel like Selena
doesn't like say much no I agree with
that like wherever they got this is
probably false but it's not the craziest
most farfetch thing I've ever heard
really cuz like they are moving kind of
fast and it has been really public and
crazy which is not something Taylor's
ever done right and Taylor's been
hanging out with her girly swirlies oh I
guess she did see Selena at the sushi
place but I feel like Selena's really
not like her BFF of this era and maybe
that's just cuz she doesn't get along
with Travis Blake is her BFF of this era
yeah and someone who's rewatching Gossip
Girl it's so crazy how far Blake Lively
has come like it's just insane Ben was
asking me last night he's like did this
show make her famous I'm like yes but
she was famous she's like probably the
only one on the show who was a like a
name before yeah from Sisterhood Of
Travel H pants yeah the traveling
hammock it was an amazing hammock
that movie was so good was that movie
based on a book yeah love that uh sorry
Brethren dropped my phone Taylor's been
blowing me up she's going to the
supermarket ask me what I want for
dinner what do you want what does Taylor
make you bro be St beef beef stew why
does she need to make a beef stew when
she got a beef stew oh t t t beef
stew yummy yummy beef
stew yummy
yummy so anyways yes Taylor's back in KC
we're spending Halloween together I'm
going to Germany this weekend to play
ball ask me why that will ever make
sense why we're playing football in
Europe when they don't give a damn about
the sport wait also did you see um this
Tuma thing that said Taylor and Travis
are planning on dressing up together for
Halloween as Posh and beex I didn't see
Posh and beex I heard that they were
spending Halloween together and there's
a party he talked about going to a party
on for Halloween on his podcast so like
they're probably
dressing up tonight we are dressing up
tonight that's like so crazy like a
couple's costume I don't think we've
ever seen Taylor in a couple's costume
yeah POS would be great like a little
too on the nose I feel like they might
be like Barbie and Ken Jackie if they
were postion backs that would be so
crazy CU we literally said that last
week that like are yeah but I feel like
that's like everybody saying that and oh
are they I thought that was like an
original thought that we had honestly oh
I feel like it's an original thought
that's like parallel to other people
having the same original thought because
it's so obvious I hate that I'm doing
this in costume but I actually needed to
correct something I said yesterday
people were mad at me and they were 100%
right like I totally [__] up what did
you say when we were talking about
Matthew Perry I just like said that he
lost his battle with addiction and like
there's no [__] proof of that so I'm
sorry to be like doing this in costume
because it's a serious thing but I am
sorry I shouldn't have said that like we
don't know no we don't know we're
waiting for toxicology reports and
autopsy um and they also said like you
were reading the TMZ like there was
nothing nefarious in his house just
prescription drugs for like diety and
anx anxiety depression and anxiety so
I'm sorry that was not cool of me and I
won't do it again that's okay tury l no
like I respect the sober community and I
feel like I offended them so I'm sorry
okay forgive
yourself it was tury not Jason just want
to I don't want to slander the good name
of the r chasing kelse I you couldn't if
you tried honestly he's
so family man he's beloved he's like
literally the mayor of Philadelphia yeah
no he really he's like Puck Satani Phil
the two of them should get together and
talk about who Philly loves more oh my
God I took my beard off I feel so much
better why don't you just take it all
the way off because it's like connected
to my wig like you could have like a
little wig adjustment moment no it's F
I'm I'm fine right now okay cool
Brethren looking good do I look
weird no I don't think so but I mean we
all look weird yeah the thing is what's
weird what is weird on Halloween so
what's your official guess for what
Taylor and I will be dressing up as
honestly like I think if Duma has Posh
and Beck like it's not that I honestly I
could not see Taylor doing something
like pop culturally or like culturally
relevant unless it's like a TV show that
she loved like if she get dressed up as
like Arya from Game of Thrones or
something because we know she used to
love Game of Thrones so I think may I
don't even know if we'll see it like if
it's a private party yeah but you know
some of his friends don't give a damn
about her privacy
y I think do you think they'll um do you
think we will violate sag afra's
policies did you see Megan fox is like
beefing with sag Afra yeah like cuz she
dressed up as Kill Bill yeah which like
I don't think anybody would have cared
but she posted a picture on Instagram
like added her whole caption was at
sagaa oh she came for them she just like
was starting stuff and then Lisa Anne
Walter who we all know as Chessie from
The Parent Trap and also the teacher in
Abid Elementary the Italian lady she um
was like responding you know beefing
with Megan Fox there's like sag aa oh
and a lot of people pointed out
yesterday we were talking about how like
Halloween felt lackluster this year in
terms of celebrity costumes a lot of
people said maybe that was due to the
sagaa
rules
maybe maybe I feel like on the one hand
I'm kind of here for like people messing
with and pushing sag afra's buttons
because they've like gotten to live out
of control but on the other hand I'm
team Chessie for life so I'm conflicted
I'm team Fran for life so right so it's
a conflict so I stand with sag you stand
with sag cuz I stand with Fran our
costumes today are sag Afra compliance
they are I think Taylor and I will be
Abra
compliant I mean she that's important to
her yeah on a serious note like she did
like go out of her way to make sure her
movie for the eras tourist was
completely compliant with sag she had an
interim agreement like she's a sag girly
but I also feel like okay maybe it was
complying with sag but it also kind of
undercut sag for her to put out a movie
when they're trying to strike and like
show Stick it to the
studios I don't think so because they
wouldn't have approved it if that was
the
case I just feel like their approvals
are willy-nilly
willy-nilly there I said it my beard is
off I'm a new woman I tried to tell you
bro you did you look nice clean cut yeah
no should Jason shave sound off in the
comments to know bro your look is too
iconic so true bro so true my brethren
bro my bro for Life bro for Life me and
you baby for Life Bowl Super by the way
I feel like this year based on what I'm
seeing it's very likely that we play
each other in the Super Bowl I'd love to
see you there at the mountain top my bro
cuz I'd rather see you out there shaking
that thing I'd rather see you rocking
the stage at the Super Bowl where is it
this year Vegas no that was last year
veg no it's in Vegas yeah I'd rather see
you out there shaking that thing rocking
the stage at at Allegient allegian stage
baby see you there allegian is like one
of the sickest stadiums it's brand new
literally looks like a club like people
have like tables and [__] this Super
Bowl is going to be sick like if I were
a player I'd want to go to this one I'm
going to try and go like that's my goal
oh that's cool I like that for you
yeah I'm going to try and go like in the
game yeah the game Brethren score a TD
you know that's has Jason Kelsey ever
scored a touchdown I know he's yes no
but he's def a he's a
tackler you know if they were playing
against a terrible team they could like
run the annexation in Puerto Rico
sometimes sometimes crazy things Kelsey
ever scored a
touchdown
no since 2011 no he's not meant to score
touchdowns in his position no no no I
think he's only on the field for defense
but like like he could do an
interception or something I think he's
an offensive tackle but still yeah yeah
he could do an interception and run it
all the way what is his
job offensive
tackle do you know how many uh Travis
has touchdowns in my career baby
yeah 100
76 got to get to
100 what position am I I keep telling
you offensive tackle that doesn't sound
like a real position OT
position
center I'm a center Center what I'm a
center you are centered you're very
centered yeah I'm a center I'm so glad
we got that straightened
out I kind of forgot you know I'm so
busy with my kids or on the
defense offense love that for you
Brethren cuz you know one thing about me
I'm going to protect my people you know
about family man one thing about me I
got a tight end that's for D I'm sure it
goes cheek crack
hole cheek crack hole say what cheek
crack hole say what Che crack hole hey
ho cheek crack
hole cheek crack that's like kind of
honestly I like being alone too much to
dance with your heart but I get lonely
when I'm alone in the dark that's
obviously the number one hit but cheek
crack hole like there's something there
if it goes like can I get a cheek crack
hole let me get a cheek crack hole cuz
it's like the the K's it really cheek
crack hole what like we could go like a
like a hip-hop route if we wanted to I
love that we could put tailor on it
she'll do her she'll come in and she'll
be like can I get a treat crack
hole
crack
hole love it Brethren love it bro by are
we still on the first story yeah yeah
yeah I'm dying so anyways TBD you guys
will see tomorrow what my girl and I
were for Halloween happy May we'll see
it tonight or maybe you'll see it
tonight depends what time my friends
upload my friends and by my friends I
mean our next story some more lovers
news your m m m
my oh
lover actually never mind Zoe cravitz
and chatting Tatum are engaged after two
years of dating sources say multiple
sources tell people exclusively the
couple who were first linked in 2021 are
recently engaged over the weekend they
were seen leading a Halloween party and
showing off her new engagement ring in
snaps I love to see a couple of lovers
doing their thing rocking the stage I do
love to see a couple of lovers rocking
the stage I love these two I think
they're so cute and honestly when he was
dating Jesse J I was obsessed with them
and when they broke up like it was hard
but the fact that both of them like
ended up so happy like she has a baby we
know that's all she's ever wanted he's
now engaged to a girl who's best friends
with Taylor Swift you'll probably be at
this
wedding oh for sure Brethren I would
love to be rocking the stage at the
wedding no I'm obsessed with these two I
think they're really cute like what an
unlikely Duo I just never would have
thought that like these two even knew
each other like chatting Tatum is in a
really weird place in his career where
like he was like very close to being a
husband yeah but he's also just like
pretty commercial mainstream obvious
he's also just like affable like I think
people like him yeah and she's very cool
she's got like the star like she's the
cool one in the relationship yeah but
Opposites Attract my brethren Opposites
Attract I mean look at me and
Kai yeah look at you and Kai we met on
Tinder know that and it was you know I
wasn't really looking for much but K man
she just came in and rocked my world at
Arrowhead she rocked your world like I
rocked the stage so true bro I mean come
on bro when are you going to settle down
I mean I'm trying I'm looking for a
breeder a what a breeder that's what he
said the a few months ago ew a woman to
have his
babies oh my god that's literally like a
disgusting way of saying it is is it a
breeder like a dog well it's just a a
technical
term bro Kai would never let me say that
never Kai's got no chill you
honestly you need to go rock the stage
in Arrowhead like you need to take a
walk
bro okay honestly I don't know what we
would be saying on this episode and
Travis didn't do that incredibly cringy
interview where he said you know I saw
her Rock the stage at Arrowhead now
should I'm going to invite her come on
come on see me rock the stage on
Arrowhead the thing is it's not that
it's just that it's the only interview
we've ever seen of his if we watch more
we would have more to say but I
personally don't need more to say no cuz
you're ready to rock the stage at
Arrowhead because it all comes back to
rocking the stage at Arrowhead so true
bro so true anyways happy for Channing
and Zoe me too actually they're really a
nice couple and I love that they're
friends with tayor swift so I'm glad
they're going the distance this a real
deal yeah just like me and Tay you and
Kai I mean me and KY
bro that's my that's my [__] right
there you know you don't think that's
disrespectful but she knows I say Kai
you're my
[__] yeah Taylor would never go for
that oh we know that we
know Different Strokes for different
folks man who going to rock the stage
the thing is the thing is and I'm so
glad you brought that up all that
matters in this life is rocking the
stage at Arrowhead
period and a discussion are you ready
for our next story yeah bro speaking of
babies Travis Barker Reveals His and
Courtney Kardashian's baby boy name and
due date after dropping hints name name
so fans had speculated that the name was
Rocky after their baby shower and he
confirmed that that is the name okay
this is like so regular yeah so regular
he said um he's going to come out of my
wife's vagina like doing front kicks and
push-ups he joked he also spilled that
the due date is either Halloween or like
the first week of November so literally
any day now if not already
um and the uh name it will be Rocky
13 um okay can we go back to the wife's
vagina thing yeah that was like him
making a joke but it's just a
lot
yeah yeah so Rocky George played guitar
for Suicidal Tendencies he said and 13
is just the greatest number of all time
he said and Rocky Tor and Rocky is the
greatest boxing movie of all time I just
want to say I actually really like the
name Rocky and I'm sure they're telling
people just because like it was leaked
by accident on Instagram so like
whatever I don't think Courtney cares
that much about like a big reveal kind
of like Kylie um maybe they wouldn't
have told everyone before the baby was
born just in case I mean in in the if
they didn't spill it the beans by
accident on Instagram stories but like
this is cute and regular of them I don't
love the whole vagina thing yeah but I
like the name I like the lack of hype
and I like the name too actually I think
Rocky is really cute I think it's really
cute a number in a name is very Elon
very XA 12
1113 and she's due any day now
so think sending her well wishes I'm
excited for her me too I'm excited for
her too this is like a really lovely
Simka and these are just nice people who
really wanted a baby and they got one
yeah it's beautiful love to see that and
I feel like next thing you know we're
going to see him rocking the stage at
Arrowhead very well could I'll be there
you know I will we would be very
receptive if he Rock if he rocked the
stage at Arrowhead and if anybody could
yeah he's a rocker he's a
rocker are you ready for our next story
no I didn't think you were Brethren
you've got a job to do is it our next
story that's brought to you by saks.com
yes look at us a couple of fashion icons
where else where else would we shop
we're saaks and EAS today's episode of
the toast is brought to you by sax.com
we are always doing our best when it
comes to looking fabulous on the podcast
sometimes our pajama uniforms and
sweatshirts do need a little bit of an
upgrade and that's why we love shopping
at saks.com from everything from podcast
luks to gno outfits and more people
don't realize how hard it is to like get
on this platform every day that's
massive and look stylish every single
day try not to repeat outfits and that's
why it's so important to build like a
really good Wardrobe full of staple
items sax is the best place for that
whatever you're shopping for so whether
you're going on vacation you need work
stuff it's really easy to find whatever
you need they make it really easy to
shop at sax.com the website has like
amazing filters for like vacations like
during they have seasonal ones like if
there's festivals going on things like
that so they just make it really easy to
find what you need and they have so much
stuff and they really do a good job of
like finding fabulous cool new Chic
Brands before everybody else does so you
can have like you know a moment and then
everybody else starts wearing this
designer and then you're like oh my God
like how did you know and it's because I
Sax Shop at sax.com that's why s sa.com
is super fun and easy to shop on whether
you're looking for a cozy Vibe a more
elevated look they've got it all at
sax.com at sax.com you can even shop by
your star sign or your situation like
you can find the perfect Revenge dress
and you can find it from Brands like
Christopher esber cult Gia and more so
discover new ways to shop for everything
every day at sax.com that's sak.com
obviously excluding today we are sax
andas every single day that's saks.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by
betterhelp do you ever feel like brain
is getting in its own way I don't know
like sometimes you can't fall asleep
because all the things that are going
wrong in your life are just like waiting
for you to start thinking about right
before you go to bed whether it's
anxiety things going on in your life
like you know what you should do for
your life you know what's good for you
but you just can't seem to do it well
therapy helps you figure out a way
figure out what's holding you back so if
you can work for yourself instead of
against yourself so if you've been
thinking about starting therapy or you
don't know where to start why don't why
don't you give better help a try better
help is done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire get match with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge I think
that's one of the best parts about
better help there's a lot of parts of
therapy that are just like awkward
social Human Social human interactions
like you know it's very common that you
start working with a therapist and it's
just not a good match there's nothing
wrong with this person it's just not a
personal match that could happen like
two or three times before you settle on
the right one and with better help
because it's done entirely online it's
just so easy and not awkward to switch
they will help you switch immediately
and then you can talk to the therapist
in whatever of what you're comfortable
with so you can do phone calls video
calls texts whatever medium makes you
feel the most
comfortable so if you want to make your
brain your friend do so with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com toast today to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com toast to get 10% off your first
month of therapy with better help make
your brain make your brain your friend
with better help betterhelp.com
toast thanks Brethren you always do the
best job you're welcome bro we love our
sponsors here we love our sponsors here
shout out to the toasty Heights sponsors
we love you we respect you and we can't
wait for our continued
partnership our next story Adele gets
emotional at a concert after seeing the
doctor who delivered her son she said
I'm desperate for another so on Saturday
as she was performing When We Were Young
during her weekends with the Dell
residency at the Coliseum at Caesar's
Palace she stopped mid song to greet the
Doctor Who delivered her son back in
2012 she said oh my God Colin oh my God
this is the doctor that gave birth to my
baby I haven't seen you in years she
went and gave him a hug and said sorry
um she was a little emotional elsewhere
during the show she opened up about her
hopes to add another little one to her
life she said I'm desperate for another
baby Colin bloody hell she had said back
in August that I really want to be a mom
again soon I've actually been writing
lists so every time I see a name that I
like I write it down on my phone yeah I
feel like when Adele's residency first
started there was like so much news
about like people coming and who she
because she does that thing where she
walks around during When We Were Young
and she like says hi to people fans
friends I saw Hillary Clinton was there
and that like kind of slowed down but
now it's coming back and this is so cute
like I feel like is cute I feel like
Adele does this part of her show When We
Were Young just to remind everyone like
she's a nice person like cuz every time
there's every time she does a show
there's a story about it like young fan
via FaceTime like the viral the viral
moment yeah well I don't typically fall
for it but this is really cute like
imagine no it's so sweet Dr Fox coming
to see you rock the stage at Arrowhead
Rock the stage at the Coliseum right
that would be so emotional you're
thinking when we were young and she
wants to a baby like it's too much it's
too much by the way I was going to say I
don't know how ad delic doesn't cry at
every show but I'm pretty sure she does
yeah that's like part of the show yeah
no and as someone who saw the show
I can tell you literally I was sobbing
it's so good yeah that's pretty cool
Brethren that you got to see that yeah
bro bro what is a your girl Taylor think
of a Dale I was just wondering the same
I've never asked her she's never come up
neither one of them have ever really
like acknowledged each other I feel like
Adele is always acknowledging Beyonce
yeah and so is Taylor and vice versa
yeah beyon is just kind of like the
bridge for all the pop stars and her
don't really have mutual friends no and
it's I don't know I feel like in
interviews like Adele is the type of
person people always get asked about and
so is Taylor Swift but neither one of
them have been asked about each other
yeah there's beef by the way but I feel
like they have mutual friends am I
making St something
up no they have mutual friends Emma
Stone Emma
Stone remember when Adele went out with
Emma Stone and Jennifer Lawrence in New
York and it was like the coolest like
group of people have never never existed
yeah and Emma Stone is so tight with
Taylor okay so one and Jennifer Lawrence
was at the ARs tour so I assume they're
friends friendly friendly
friendly no one's closer with her than
me bro we're like this who are you
closer with bro me or Taylor oh you're
my brethren from day one Bros for Life
Bros for Life bro let me tell you I
borrowed this jacket from Becky from the
redheads M because I didn't own any
Eagles jersey and I'm rifling through
her Pockets like an animal you want to
know what's in here I guess so a receipt
from jeffree's grocery store I don't
even know where that is a w place maybe
it's in Philly she spent $57 M and some
matches from EMTs oh EMT on Grove I
actually just ate here it's pretty
good cool I'll leave it in there when I
return the jacket that's what you should
do yeah yeah yeah cuz I'd rather see you
out there rocking the stage at Arad what
don't we all I'm really conflating those
two lines I'd rather see you out there
shaking that thing
and come see me rock the stage at
Arrowhead it's the same energy it's the
same it's giving Kevin G he is killer
Trav Kevin G killer Trav is Kevin G
100% let's do our fifth and final story
so that you can get back to training for
this weekend now that I'm me put my
beard back on for the fifth and final
story like I got to get back to my girl
we've only got a few days before I'm
headed off to Frankfurt she's going to
South America it's hard times bro but
we'll make it through I'm ready
Bridgerton actress suffered two
psychotic breaks from that show she said
calling out Netflix and shandan for not
providing support she said she was
deteriorating while filming so
Bridgerton actress Ruby Barker called
out Netflix and shaelan for failing to
support her during two psychotic breaks
that occurred in the wake of the romance
series block Blockbuster success bar was
a series regular she played Marina the
featherington cousin whose scandalous
pregnancy made her a social Pariah in
Regency Era London she said her first
psychotic break happened in 2019 after
she got production on Bridgerton season
1 a second one occurred in 2022 but she
said she got no support from Netflix so
she was on a podcast recently and said
not a single person from Netflix not a
single person from shaelan since I have
had two psychotic breaks from that show
have even contacted me or emailed me to
ask if I'm okay or if I would benefit
from any sort of after or support she
said her mental health started declining
during the filming of Bridgerton she
claimed her character's isolated nature
negatively impacted her quote during
filming I was deteriorating it was a
really tormenting place for me because
my character was very alienated very
ostracized on her own under these
horrible
circumstances when I went into Hospital
a week after shooting Bridgerton season
1 it was really covered up and kept on
the down low because the show was going
to be coming out in the runup to the
show coming out I was just coming out
from the hospital my Instagram following
was going up I had all these engagements
to do my life was changing drastically
overnight and yet there was still no
support and there still hasn't been any
support all that time so I was really
trying really really hard to act like it
was okay and I could work and that it
wasn't a
problem so did you have the break after
after season 1 came out and then like
during season
two and so she's where was she giving
this interview on a podcast called um
Loaf and I'm assuming she is not
returning for the next season well I
guess it would matter like it would
depend on where her character was at I
feel like they kind of closed the book
on Marina she yeah her character
actually ended up like happy yeah and
she insane was in like that one episode
where Colin came to see her to kind of
like get closure and he she like had a
baby and she was actually really happy
her husband like didn't bother her and
she lived in a big house and she could
have had such a worse life because she
got pregnant right right like it was the
best of all outcomes I so I guess like I
mean her story is over you're right it
doesn't make sense for her character to
have to be in season 3 and it clearly
doesn't make sense for this actress to
re rejoin I'm saying like wouldn't be
talking publicly negatively about
Netflix if she was you know waiting on
them for a paycheck that's true so I'm
assuming she's done yeah I guess we can
say that would connote she's done I mean
I just think this is
like Hollywood isn't good for mental
health what like we you know they're not
like a super caring no industry it's
like a Cutthroat Fu industry yeah so
it's important to keep that in mind yeah
and I feel bad for her like that's
really like a psychotic break that's not
like you know that's a small thing
that's no small thing like you have to
be get like in a hospital like that's
serious yeah and the fact that nobody
reached out to her like I'm shocked
like's disgusting like what are we yeah
yeah maybe a different industry a
different yeah
honestly the fact that she's speaking
out against Netflix that like puts a
stain on your sort of reputation people
aren't going to want to work so maybe
she doesn't give a [__] anymore you know
yeah same for shondel land too like yeah
shondel land is like big and beloved
yeah so and also it just is like oh
you're going to like talk negatively
about us bite the hand that feeds you
sort of thing like they both other again
like even a different place so I'm sure
she's done which sounds like it's for
the best yeah when is bton coming back
because it's it's her it's her time
right I feel like it's almost time for
uh who's that wench Penelope Nicola her
name is Nicola in real life Penelope
yeah and but this probably be a good
season cuz spoiler alert
right what's she's oh spoiler alert if
you didn't watch Bridgerton yet just
mute for a second she's lady Missle down
but we already knew that yeah but the
tund is going to find out cuz it's like
about her that's true and her friend
knows Eloise Elise oh she's so [__]
self-righteous I hate that [__] she's
my least favorite character Eloise
greater than Penelope for me right now
no towards the end of last season yeah
Penelope [__] up but like she's a
sweet girl and she's like kind of
pathetic no she's kind of an
ARS an ARS yeah she's kind of an ARs and
she's got let the power go to her head
by the way breaking news Travis calls
Penelope from Bridgerton a positively an
a
positive ARS ARS is this such a good
insult it is Taylor and I were watching
Bridgerton she had the same Taylor
definitely loves Bron I know but it's
kind of Kim's thing I know Taylor
definitely loves Bridgerton but I feel
like if she did she would like make it
her personality so maybe she never saw
it but Taylor doesn't like make stuff
her personality no but like she
incorporates things that she loves like
Game of Thrones yeah but we find out
like years later and she becomes friends
with people
she's not friends with phoe she should
be friends with Phoebe Denver
yeah yes she should some Miss she has a
lot of friends like who needs more she
always my girl always wants more friends
she's hanging out with Britney jackon
the gang well I can't believe we made it
through this whole episode without
talking about Jackson moms I mean listen
that's Pat's little bow mad love it's
cat's little bow that's family to me bro
yeah yeah I
mean okay not like you not like you and
my nieces but that's family bro Pat me
can't come between us bro I cannot wait
to see you for the holidays like family
back together mom's home cooking you
know is Taylor
coming so Taylor's on tour but we're
trying to make something
work well you know you're always welcome
at at me and K's Place Kasa Kelsey Kasa
Kylie Kelsey well bro you know I love
you I love working with you I love doing
the show Good Luck this weekend you too
can't wait to see you rock the stage at
Arrowhead I'll be in [__] Frankfurt I
told
you I'll be rocking the stage in [__]
Frankfurt oh my God should be rocking
the stage at [__] Frankfurt like why
bro why can't I be rocking the stage at
our head why do I have to go to Germany
let me be honest like I'm so relieved
that Dad Ain me bro not this weekend but
you know that NFL they're going to make
you go to [__] Frankfurt I hope
everybody enjoyed toast doing 2023
honestly nailed it crushed it mik drop
we love you guys we'll see you tomorrow
back for normal episode where we'll look
so much more beautiful thank you so much
for listening to the new heights the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so for watching this on YouTube
Bro subscribe bro we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found Spotify iTunes Stitch public radio
I cast box old places whereever you
listen a podcast find us the toast I
don't know where the accent is going
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are and tell them how we rock the
stage tell them how we rock the stage
and
arrowead love you guys bye love you
bye love you
bye